in 2013 I pretended to be a red coat
security guard at a Laker game but what
was the name of my character
a bend over
B Ted vagina
see Harry peanuts in the hairy peanuts
and what bend over be Ted vagina really
Ted vagina wow
hi I'm Will Farrell I'm Ryan Reynolds
and we're about to play do you even know
me I don't know why I added that sass
I'm sorry no I liked it too okay give it
like a real game show feedback I'll
begin if that's all right please
what was I voted by my classmates at
school a most handsome
be most likely to end up in prison see
best personality
hmm you're probably like me late bloomer
I'm going to say C best personality
most likely they end up in prison wow
really no you're right see
personality which famous actor did I
kiss at the 2017 Golden Globes a Tom
Holland B Andrew Garfield C Toby Maguire
Toby McGuire no Andrew Garfield
in a word yes gorgeous gorgeous dreamy
because I lost the reward to Ryan
Gosling who went up and said and
Garfield and I were like you know
Garfield's like stuck if if you win
don't kiss your wife just kiss me and I
was like done done and then Gosling one
and Garfield was just like we were just
all right let's just do it just in the
Deep backwards very you're like what the
hell's happened one of my early jobs was
working in a hotel but what was my role
a spa manager
uh B valet
c pot washer I'm gonna say pot washer c
pot washer although that's a very
specific thing to wash E I was a valet
in fact I left someone's keys in someone
else's car's car who left for the night
this is in Southern California and I was
not fired wow
wow I don't know how that happens
because you have a great personality
great personality okay which of these
classes did I fail at school a biology b
Drama come on C gym
I know you're a hell of an athlete you
suffered multiple concussions playing
football is this true uh I'm gonna say
biology
wrong drama drama oh yeah spicy theater
coach did not like the other stuff away
and you had too many questions didn't
you yeah Galloway well I didn't show up
a lot okay so attendance in 2013 I
pretended to be a red coat security
guard at a Laker game but what was the
name of my character
a bend over
B Ted vagina
see Harry peanuts and hairy peanuts
hey what bend over be Ted vagina really
dead vagina wow
really yeah I know the bed because they
yeah that took some guts took some I
thought they didn't really know right oh
boy what April Fool's prank got me
kicked out of school oh that's a good
one a put a rotten fish in my teacher's
desk B stole my teacher's car or C
Street during a high school football
game
[Music]
I'm gonna see
I'm gonna say for fun you stole your
teacher's card that is correct will I
along with several other friends
including uh Jimmy barbutis stole our
teacher's car by lifting it we actually
lifted it and and walked away yeah
because we didn't have driver's license
exposed to that I was suspended for that
yeah it must have been a SubCom it must
have been a compact car is it Volkswagen
Bug easy yeah no big yeah good deal Ryan
close your eyes
what color are my eyes
green
or blue what do you mean come on like
I'm staring at them forever oh wait
what color are my eyes
I read that one they're green blue are
they great oh I guess they are a little
bit green yeah
is dreamy a color I think it is now yeah
where do I keep my Deadpool costume in
my house
a I'm sad B A bedside drawer B on a
mannequin in the basement or C turned it
into a pillow
I'm going to say on a mannequin in the
basement correct yep
yep yeah is it still there
it is yeah terrifies my kids but yeah
it's just standing there and it reeks
yeah well came that way
which of these pranks did I pull at
College a brought a herd of goats into
the college Auditorium be dressed up as
the janitor and walked into my friend's
classes pretending to do odd jobs C put
toothpaste and a load of Dunkin Donuts
and sold them around campus well B for
sure you came in as a janitor and did
bits I did yeah we had a lit cigarette
how did you come up with that it's
amazing friend that well that's so but
if you think about it that's so on brand
it's just the weird things I would think
about what is my middle name a Rodney B
Milhouse C Ryan Rodney it's not Ryan
Ryan Reynolds what is my middle name
Sabrina Ryan correct
Ryan John or will
uh it is uh John very much John no no oh
it's will cause will is your middle name
and John is your first name John William
John William Serena
yeah John Williams Serena Farrell
Sabrina uh I own a football team you
came to watch a match with me what is
the team I own called
wrexham football club yeah I think the
mascot is the mascot like a griffin or
something or uh it is the red dragon but
it's also been a robin in the past yeah
why they never made it a T-Rex like with
the spelled with the w would have I
don't know it's an opportunity what was
the name of the song
uh John C Reilly and myself saying to
our dad during a business pitch
jiggle jiggle jiggle B Lust For Life
Insurance C boats and hoes wait oh
oh that's a different song boats and
hoes yes right yes which of these
unusual skills can I do a a standing
backflip B solve a Rubik's Cube in under
one minute or C hold my breath for three
minutes uh I want to say but I don't
know if you can do it now but at some
point a standing backflip that is true I
don't think I would do it now in a
hospital Lobby right so I would get
instant care but you used to be able to
do it yeah
for real yeah that was fun yeah
what degree did I get
a accountancy and management you can
tell this was written by Brits account I
know this already though and management
I know Canadian studies well every
college has that
c sports information sports information
yeah
in my early career which TV show pilot
did I star in a friends B whoa speak of
the devil Sabrina the Teenage Witch or C
Star Trek
Sabrina the TV yes very good yes which
famous basketball player do I part own
Los Angeles football club with a LeBron
James B Magic Johnson C Michael Jordan
Magic Johnson
correct
we'll actually won that game but I feel
it was very tight I do too I feel it was
very tight but I'm also comfortable to
win with Will winning
feel good about that okay
and my husband this because he's like
this is so weird that we have to be
to be throw his bunny out of bed no yeah
and I get so mad I'm like everybody out
of bed oh the things bunny has seen yeah
well no I shouldn't see that anyways no
no sorry